quand on mange de l'argent tous les ans
moi je m'appelle pas bê encour donc j'ai
pas les moyens de payer des pertes à
longueur de
temps et nous accueillons notre invité
du samedi 20h ce soir pierre Priolet
bonsoir
bonsoir alors pierre 1 an après votre
inoubliable témoignage sur ce plateau à
quelques jours du Salon de l'Agriculture
vous revoilà à l'occasion de la public
chez Robert Laffond d'un livre intitulé
Les fruits de ma colère alors pierre il
y a un an vous nous expliquiez que vous
touchiez 17 centimes d'euros sur 1 kil
de pomme vendu dans la grande
distribution 3 € un an plus tard vous
venez nous annoncer que vous avez
arracher les pommiers les poiriers et
les
pommiers pierre prol bonsoir à quelques
jours du salon de l'agriculture et à
l'occasion la publication chez Robert
Laffond de votre livre les fruits de ma
colère nous sommes très heureux de vous
retrouver ça va ça va je vous remercie
alors vous avez fait une entrée
fracassante sur la scène médiatique le
17 décembre 2009 ce jour-l vous écoutter
France interre où le ministre de
l'Agriculture Bruno Lemire est invité et
le ministre parle d'une chute des
revenus des paysans en 2009 de 34 % là
ça vous fout rogne parce que pour perdre
34 % de ses revenus encore faut-il avoir
des revenus et là vous décidez d'appeler
France Inter vous dites j'ai appeler
sans trop savoir pourquoi j'en pouvais
plus d'entendre ces conneries c'est
exact votre passage à l'antenne fait un
tabac vous devenez en quelque sorte le
porte-parole malgré vous du monde
agricole et vous êtes définitivement
admis dans votre milieu d'adoption parce
qu'au départ vous n'êtes pas né
agriculteur tout à fait alors ce n'est
qu'au début des années 90 dis que vous
achetez 13 hectares à molégess en
Provence pour vous lancer dans la
production de pommes et de poir là vous
investissez 600000 € et vous devez
attendre 10 ans avant que vos arbres
vous rapportent quelque chose ce n'est
qu'en l'an 2000 que vous commercialisez
vos fruits ça apprend la patience hein
nous on vit avec les saisons on vit avec
le temps on sait très bien qu'un arbre
pour arriver à pleine maturité il lui
faut du temps alors de 2000 à 2010 votre
exploitation ne sera bénéficiire que 2
ans en 2009 vos pertes s'élèvent à
120000 € h et le problème en fait c'est
que vous vendez à perte quoi c'est que
vous vendez des fruits 17 centimes
d'euros et en fait il vous coûte déjà 40
et quand vous les retrouvez dans un un
supermarché ils sont vendus 3 € je me
suis rendu compte de quoi c'est que plus
l'homme travaillait moins il gagnait et
plus la société se satisfaisait du hold
up permanent qui est fait au producteurs
en général et aujourd'hui on est en
train de sacrifier un pays uniquement
par la p du gain et ça c'est
insupportable c'est vrai que 17 centimes
d'euros vous le retrouvez à 3 € chez
Carrefour ou chez auchochamp euh c'est
difficile d'autant plus que le ministre
nous dit il faut privilégier les
circuits courts il n'y a pas plus court
que les circuits aujourd'hui nous
produisons des fruits nous les portons à
nos partenaires les OP les coopérativ ou
les commerçants et immédiatement la
grande surface est chez eux par le biais
des référencements
oua
payéé distribution c'est inacceptable
voilà alors évidemment le risque à terme
c'est que la production de de fruits de
légumes soit entièrement délocalisée
dans des pays où la main d'œuvre est
moins chère toutit des fruits traités
avec des produits phytosanitaires
interdits en France alors que vous les
produits phytosanitaires vous coûtent
très cher vous dites en 5 ans je suis
passé de 18000 € par an à 36000 € par an
tout à fait lorsqu'on nous interdit un
produit phytosanitaire efficace de suite
l'industrie phytosanitaire multiplie par
5 son remplaçant ouais ce qui fait qu'on
on est pris au piège de ces
interdictions parce qu'en fait
l'agriculteur il n'emploie aucun produit
qui n'it pas été agréé par l'État ouais
s'il y a des critiques à faire c'est à
l'État c'est pas au paysan ouais il faut
arrêter de déconner donc j'en ai Mar des
traité de pollueurs vous dites le succès
de l'écologie est en train de causer la
perte des agriculteurs en fait on a
vraiment eu besoin des écologiste pour
nous amener à une vraie réflexion tout
ce que je dis quand on fait de
l'écologie il faut jamais oublier que
l'homme est au centre de tout or
aujourd'hui en ne pensant qu'à la nature
aujourd'hui on est en train de sacrifier
tous nos paysans et ça c'est
inacceptable je le voit dans nos dans
dans les porcheries par exemple qui sont
à l'agonie aujourd'hui les suicides
c'est vraiment
ce compte tous les jours qui a poussé
tous ces éleveurs à faire ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui l'État l'agroalimentaire
l'industrie et ça il faut qu'on arrête
le cinéma alors depuis qu'on s'est vu
l'année dernière pierre vous avez créé
consomm juste vous avez un slogan
formidable consommer juste et pas juste
consommer c'est très bien aujourd'hui ce
qui m'affolle c'est de voir des
politiques qui pensent que santé c'est
en relançant la consommation qu'on va
sauver les pays c'est une crétinerie on
a une une génération qui a rempli les
poubelles on a été une génération qui
avont gaspillé le monde les ressources
énergétiques toutes les ressources du
monde et aujourd'hui on dit à nos jeunes
privez-vous payez nos excès il faut
arrêter maintenant alors après votre
passage dans salul ériien vous avez été
contacté par Jean-François saut le
patron de Buffalo grille il vous appelle
et vous dit j'ai été très ému par votre
témoignage je n'imaginais pas que le
désarroi des agriculteurs était aussi
profond alors il vous propose de mettre
à votre disposition la disposition des
producteurs des fruits et légumes sur
des parkings formidable parce que d'un
seul coup c'est vraiment du producteur
au consommateur là en fait ça répondait
un petit peu à la demande ou à la
proposition que j'avais fait ouais
est-ce que Buffalo vous leur avez parlé
aussi du lait et de la viande parce
qu'ils importent aussi non ça a été la
première des discussions quand il m'a
appelé je lui ai dit je peux pas
accepter ouais vous vendez de la viande
d'éleveurs qui sont en train de crever
de faim on a passé 15 jours échange on
s'est mis d'accord il était à 25 % de
viande il est passé à 50 % de viande
française et 100 % de la viande hachée a
été proposée française très bien
donc
alors là où c'est très triste c'est
l'épilogue de votre livre le 4 novembre
2010 quand les tractopel viennent
arracher vos arbres quand on mange de
l'argent tous les ans moi je m'appelle
pas bê en cours donc j'ai pas les moyens
de payer des pertes à longueur de temps
donc à partir du moment où je constate
qu'en 3 ans 260000 € sont perdus aucun
revenu
ouais est-ce que est-ce qu'on a le choix
ouais quand vous avez la gangraine il y
a pas 50 solutions il faut couper fort
vous faites arracher vos arbres quand
même j'imagine que ça doit être un
déchirement pour vous bien sûr c'est
quand même 20 ans d'investissement qui
partent en fumée donc bien sûr que c'est
terrible mais c'est terrible pour tous
les arbculteurs de ma région moi on m'a
filmé combien d'arbres ont é arraché
chez moi il faut savoir que sur ma
commune so % de la commune est en friche
le pays a dit vous êtes de trop on vous
supprime le pays va le payer cher toutes
nos élites aujourd'hui qui raisonnent
ferit bien de penser à demain comment
peut-on penser que toute l'alimentation
va être importée il faut être crétin
c'est impossible de continuer dans cette
voie moi je dis aujourd'hui c'est l'État
qui est en cause dans un marché de
Truant la règle est à mettre par l'État
et moi je dis qu'aujourd'hui de même
qu'on prend l'autoroute et que c'est
l'État qui fixe les tarifs l'État
devrait dire la grande distribution oui
30 % de marge maximum là ils vont se
remettre à travailler là ils auront plus
intérêt à aller chercher à 10 centimes
les produits et les vendre à 3 € il
faudra simplement qu'il payent le juste
prix et à 30 centimes 30 % s'ils veulent
gagner leur vie faudra qu'il bosse ouais
vous dénoncez la collusion du pouvoir
avec les grandes surfaces depuis les
années 60 c'est une vraie pieuvre qui
s'est installée dans le pays à tel point
que ça devenait ement énorme qu' a une
loi pour geler le territoire et la
pieuvre recommence vous avez bien vu que
les clients commencent à déserter les
grands centres commerciaux ils ont
réinvesti les centr-villes pour empêcher
la concurrence vrai ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui on est dans un état qui a
protéger ces gens-là n'importe qui à
leur place fait pareil parce que l'État
les y autorise ils sont dans la loi donc
j'accuse l'état de non assistance à
personnes en danger de mise à mort du
monde agricole par le la le la lâcheté
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui à abandonné
complètement leur agriculture le pays
profond la France profonde aujourd'hui
qu'on voit mourir vous allez au milieu
de la France c'est un mouroir c'est la
fin des paysans vous croyez
non non je dis aux jeunes formez-vous à
ce beau métier c'est le plus beau métier
du monde on vit en harmonie avec la
nature on est heureux quand on a fait un
bon boulot et vous aurez du boulot dans
les 5 à 10 ans qui viennent c'est sûr
oui comme il y a une rarefction euh des
matièrees premières agricole sur toute
la planète on peut imaginer qu'un jour
faud bien refaire de la culture ici he
c'est un très beau métier et c'est un
métier créateur d'emploi comment l'État
peut pas voir qu'on peut mettre des
millions d'hommes sur ces terres qui
sont en train d'être aujourd'hui
abandonnés mais enfin on est nourrissier
notre but à nous c'est de nourrir nos
semblables comment on arrive à faire
crever de faim des gens qui sont faits
pour nous nourrir vous l'avez vu Bruno
Le
Maire mais le problème c'est quand les
gensun fois que le livre a été écrit on
lui a dit Monsieur le Maire est-ce qu'on
pourrait prévoir il a dit je suis très
occupé aujourd'hui vous faites quoi
alors c'est c'est la une folie on va
faire de la salade de la salade oui avec
des méthodes écologiques parce que je
suis quand même interpellé par par le
discours et par l'attente de la société
donc je vais faire des salades avec une
méthode life une méthode anglaise qui se
rapproche vraiment du de de du bio ouais
et je vais voir ce que ça donne José
moi ce qui me frappe le plus c'est la
réalité par rapport au marché c'est que
aujourd'hui les paysans grandes quantité
de paysans sont payés en dessous de leur
coût de production j'ai fait voter c'est
invraisemblable j'ai fait voter pour la
première fois au Parlement européen par
600 députés un texte pour dire il n'est
pas normal que l'agriculture soit payée
en dessous de ses cûts de production
c'est la base et en même temps alors les
fruits les légumes actuellement l'Europe
est en train de passer un accord
complètement en silence avec le Maroc
pour augmenter les importations de
tomates de courgette de d'agrum et
cetera et cetera c'est une horreur de
manière invraisemblable sans qu'il y a
aucune garantie pour les producteur
demain le même accord est prévu avec
l'Amérique du Sud pour l'importation de
viande bovine et le troisième accord qui
est dans les discussion c'est avec le
Canada pour le lait ce qui veut dire que
si ces accords passent il y a plus
d'agriculur on est en train de liqu mais
parce qu'il y avait pas de Rouston dans
notre pays nos politiques ont tout
abandonné au poignon la la dérégulation
c'est quoi il y a 80 % de main d'œuvre
dans une pomme ouais c'est certain que
si un homme travaille à 10 € par jour il
est évident qu' il sera plus performant
que moi 12,50 € de l'heure et nos
politiques ont fait quoi ah le marché ah
il va réguler mais plus crétin que ça tu
meurs le marché ne s'autorégule pas tout
seulement à ce qu'elle nous a raconté
je reviens à ce que José nous disait il
y a quelques années sur la
marchandisation du monde et depuis 92 99
2003 toutes les réformes de la politique
agricole se sont fait pour aligner les
prix des matières premières sur les
règles de l'OMC ce qui fait qu'on a plus
de prix intérieur européen ce sont les
prix du marché mondial ça nexiste pas
marché monondi vous qui êtes députés
européens est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
avoir un protectionnisme européen je
parle pas d'un protectionnisme français
mais mais un protectionisme européen au
moins non mais moi que ce que je veux de
manière évidente c'est de dire pourquoi
est-ce qu'on doit importer alors qu'on
est capable de le produire oui monsieur
Tron un mot même si vous n'êtes pas
ministre de l'Agriculture non je suis
pas ministre de l'Agriculture et pour
être très sincère c'est très difficile
de prendre la parole après vous j'espère
bien ah ben ça vous dérange pas je le
tente quand même je quand même vous dire
deux trois choses la première je crois
que contrairement à ce que vous avez
indiqué il y a pas que des crétins qui
se succèdent depuis 30 ans à la tête de
l'État que on peut on peut contester ben
je vous réponds on peut contester et je
comprends très bien l'argumentation j
décision ont été pris mais on est dans
un monde aujourd'hui s'internationalise
dans tous les domaines et qu que soi les
difficultés pas les G quiuisent on le
dit la globalisation Mo je vous dis
banglad un ministre
gag00
€ ne criez pas et partez de l'idée que
pour défendre bien une idée tout alors
écoutez si vous êtes
convaincu onement la parole c'est pas
une raison pourquoi vous la prenez faire
en sorte que plus personne ne
puissexprimer on vous a entendu on
respecte votre émotion régler le
problème ce soir en tous les cas
continuez votre combat parce que nous
les consommateurs avons tout
gagner merci beaucoup et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater debe abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce
bleu